this is a very interesting
john voight uh the actor father of
angelina jolie
um he has been a right wing guy for a
while now pro-trump guy kind of a maga
hero
jon voight has gone off script as far as
the maga people are concerned after the
uvaldi texas shooting and is now saying
oh we need screening and we need testing
for people who are going to have
firearms this is absolutely fascinating
around election 2020
john voight said he thought that he and
donald trump were are in our greatest
fight since the civil war
uh he has uh you know he used to be kind
of like a moderate he supported jfk
and whatever but he's gone completely
off the rails more recently
conspiratorial stuff talking about uh
democratic propaganda with subliminal
messages that obama was a god-like
figure that he would be make america
socialist like jon voight went hard
right and pro-trump
and all of a sudden
in the last few days uh two days ago
right after the uvalde texas shooting he
put out what i would argue are the
sanest words he would he has spoken in
years
going 180
from what the maga people believe take a
look at this sure that we will never see
this horror again in this lifetime
we must identify every individual for
their credentials for their mental
capacity to bear arms right there should
be proper qualifications for gun
ownership and proper testing
one should only own a gun if they're
qualified and schooled
i stand with all i stand for freedom of
each soul's truths
i stand for god's truths i stand for one
to be condemned for evil doings now he
he still can't get away from this weird
conspiratorial religious speak he can't
even get away from that in this segment
but he's saying we need testing we need
evaluation we need licensing we need
training this is already more than
republicans are willing to concede
and that they must pay a price
may god watch over all
and bring comfort for this loss which
may never heal
for each child was so precious a gift
and god will call on jesus
to pray for these families
he loved you
yeah
so he's still a very wacky guy i'm not
going to deny that
but this is not going to
put him in the good graces of the
trumpists that's for sure but everything
jon voight is saying makes perfect sense
how do you buy over the weekend i spent
time looking at how do you get firearms
in switzerland people love to talk about
switzerland and guns how do you get guns
in a number of different countries
look at japan as an example in order to
get a gun in japan
you have to take a firearms class
and pass a written exam that's only done
three times a year so it's not like oh i
want a gun this weekend i'll just go and
do the thing this weekend that's number
one you've got to get a doctor's note
saying you're mentally fit and have no
history of drug abuse you have to apply
for a permit to take live firing
training that can take a month to get
you have to meet with police and explain
why do you need a gun
you have to pass a review of your
criminal history gun possession record
employment involvement with organized
crime personal debt relationships with
friends family and neighbors you have to
apply for a gunpowder permit you then
have to take a one-day training class
and pass a firing test you've got to get
a certificate from a gun dealer
describing the firearm that you're
looking to get to to buy
then you've got a if you want a hunting
gun apply for a hunting license you have
to buy a gun safe and an ammunition
lopper locker that meets safety
regulations you then have to let police
come in and inspect that you actually
have the proper storage setup you pass
one more additional background review
and at that point you are given a permit
with which you can go
and get your gun
you can still get a gun
but there is serious scrutiny of the
people that are looking to do it
many of those elements
are part of what i've laid out and i
have to tell you
all my liberal gun owning friends
are fine with everything on my list and
why wouldn't they be because their goal
isn't more guns and more places their
goal is we have a second amendment
different people might have different
reasons for wanting to have a firearm
which by the way might include that so
many right wingers have them
and i'm willing to go through a
difficult process
because it will make me feel better that
only people who really safely can have
firearms have them
it's uh
listen as far as jon voight goes it's
glad to see him talk a little sense it's
been about a decade of him not making
any sense unfortunately sadly
um
i don't know that any of those things i
mentioned last week or that john voigt
mentioned in his in his clip are going
to become a reality anytime soon but we
are seeing some cracks with a few
republicans saying okay
now it's too far
now we finally have to do something
we'll soon see whether they do